vamos con el problema 84 en el problema
84 nos dice que en un crucero dos
terceras partes de los pasajeros son
empleados le voy a poner así dos
empleados son empleados y el resto son
turistas entonces una tercera parte de
los pasajeros son turistas muy bien y
luego nos dicen si tres cuartas partes
de los empleados son administradores ok
entonces tres cuartas partes de los
empleados de los empleados son
administradores entonces cuál es el
número de empleados que no son
administradores empleados que no son
administradores ok entonces nos están
pidiendo determinar cuánto es un cuarto
d
tres cuartas partes de los empleados
administradores queremos los empleados
no administradores o sea la cuarta parte
que falta creo que esto es más
complicado por por las palabras que por
las matemáticas pero bueno vamos a ver
qué opciones nos dan opción 1 hubo 690
pasajeros en el crucero 690 pasajeros
pasajeros pues esto es suficiente verdad
aquí todo está muy relacionado si
conocemos los pasajeros conocemos los
empleados si conocemos los empleados
conocemos pues la cuarta parte de los
empleados conocemos también los
administradores conocemos los turistas
vaya los pasajeros nos da toda la
información como le haríamos pues
también tenemos que lo que nos interesa
un cuarto de es igual a un cuarto de dos
terceras partes de los pasajeros dos
terceras partes de los pasajeros que
sería un cuarto de dos terceras partes
de 690 no lo vamos a simplificar porque
únicamente nos interesa que esta
información es suficiente vamos al
inciso 2 me les hizo 2 lo que nos dice
es que hay 230 pasajeros que son
turistas de que son turistas pues del
crucero entonces nos están diciendo que
te en la cantidad de turistas es igual a
230 bueno pues si tenemos que éste es
igual a 230 entonces podemos determinar
la cantidad
la cantidad de pasajeros es tres veces
este que es igual a 690 que nos regresa
a la información que teníamos en el
inciso 1 con la cual ya vimos que
podemos terminar entonces el inciso 2
por sí mismo también es suficiente y por
lo tanto la respuesta es de vamos al
problema 85 problema 85 dice en el plano
xy el punto 412 está en la línea k
queremos saber si el 412 está
está en la línea k bueno vamos a dibujar
un plano xy para entender un poco mejor
esta pregunta ahí tenemos nuestro plano
ojalá eso sea suficiente
por ahí voy a poner el eje por acá el
eje x y vamos a ver qué información nos
dan a ver el inciso 1 de información nos
dice que el punto 17 está en la línea k
17 en la línea k entonces digamos que
aquí es 1 x 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 más o menos
por acá este punto sabemos que está en
la línea k bueno a partir de eso
podremos decir algo del punto 4 12 o sea
digamos 1 2 3 4 pues como por acá más o
menos ese punto de ahí el 4,12 podemos
saber si está en la línea k pues no o
sea saber que que la línea k pasa por
aquí todavía no nos dice gran cosa la
línea podría ser así así así así así
entonces esto todavía no nos dice
lo que nos dice el inciso 2 es que el
punto menos 22 está en la línea k menos
está en la línea k otra vez por sí mismo
eso simplemente nos dice que la línea
esté acá pasa por un cierto punto el
menos 12 como a 12 como por ahí sale
entonces estoy acá es el menos 22 este
de acá es el 17 pero saber que la línea
acá pasa por aquí tampoco nos dice gran
cosa sin embargo si juntamos los dos si
juntamos los dos entonces ya sabemos
quién es la línea acá es la línea que
pasa por estos dos entonces sería más o
menos a ver si me queda voy a usar la
herramienta de línea a ver qué tal me
queda nos quedaría más o menos algo así
y pues al parecer sí sí parece que el
punto 4,12 está ahí vamos a ver si está
o si no está entonces éste acá sería el
4,12 y lo que yo haría para ver si está
o no de ono esta sería calcular esta
pendiente de la pendiente de la recta y
ver si con esa misma pendiente llegamos
a este punto sí sí entonces este punto
va a estar por acá vale déjame tomar la
herramienta para escribir entonces
necesitamos encontrar la pendiente de
esta recta la pendiente sería
2 o sea 5 dividido entre 1 - menos 25
tercios para entonces la pendiente aquí
es cinco tercios y de este lado es 12
menos 7 o sea 5 dividido entre 4
135 tercios entonces en efecto este
punto está aquí que eso es justo lo que
queríamos a no espérame tantito creo que
ya perdimos mucho tiempo bueno está bien
porque vimos una técnica nueva en
realidad todo esto que hicimos hasta el
final sería una gran pérdida de tiempo
en el examen de james nosotros no
necesitábamos saber o bueno no
necesitábamos responder sí sí estaba
este punto en esta recta de acá
únicamente necesitábamos saber si la
combinación de estos dos pedazos de
información nos permitía concluirlo
entonces el primero no porque sólo nos
da este que la recta pasa por un punto
el segundo por sí mismo tampoco pero si
los juntamos tenemos la recta y entonces
uno debe de decir ah ya con eso ya puedo
saber si el punto está en la recta 1
pero no tendría que hacerlo a fuerzas al
menos no en el examen de game at vale
lo único que nos interesa es que si se
puede responder esta pregunta la
respuesta no nos interesa pero entonces
la respuesta del problema sería se sale
por separado no podemos responder pero
juntándolos si podemos responder la
pregunta muy bien vamos al problema
86-86 but entonces en el problema 86 nos
dice que la longitud de la barda que
rodea a un jardín circular que es un
medio es un medio de la longitud que
rodea a un segundo ok mejor hago el
dibujo y lo leo con calma entonces
tenemos por aquí un primer jardín vale y
tenemos un segundo jardín que al parecer
bueno que según la información es más
grande y de hecho desde el doble va
entonces este primer jardín se llama el
jardín este acá y estoy acá es el jardín
y entonces lo que nos dice es que la
longitud la longitud de la
que rodea al jardín acá vamos a ponerle
vamos a ponerle pe de perímetro entonces
el perímetro del jardín acá es igual a
la mitad del perímetro del jardín que es
igual a un medio del perímetro del
jardín je esto básicamente nos dice que
este tiene el doble de radio que este de
acá verdad porque el perímetro es
proporcional a los radios pues entonces
qué es lo que quieren lo que nos piden
es determinar el área del jardín que
queremos determinar el área del jardín
acá bueno pues es bueno pensar un poco
en esto antes de antes de empezar a ver
las opciones que necesitamos para tener
el área del jardín acá pues basta
conocer el radio de este jardín verdad
pero para pero conocer el radio pues
también lo podemos hacer a partir de
conocer su perímetro y conocer el
perímetro de éste lo podemos saber
conociendo el perímetro de acá que lo
podemos conocer no sé conociendo el
radio de esta o su área tenemos muchas
chances o muchas oportunidades
para determinar el área entonces vamos a
ver qué opciones nos dan vale bueno
vamos a vamos a ver qué nos da el inciso
1 el inciso 1 nos dice que el área deje
el área del jardín g es igual a 25
metros cuadrados 25 metros cuadrados a
como te decía teniendo el área de este
de acá podemos encontrar el área de este
de acá más o menos la idea de la
cadenita sería que el área de este nos
da el radio de este que nos da el
perímetro de este que nos da el
perímetro de este que nos da el radio de
este que nos da el área ahorita no lo
voy a hacer o quizás si este después
pero primero déjame analizar lados
ahorita lo que nos importa es que con
esta información tenemos suficiente para
responder la pregunta vale para
determinar esta área vamos a ver qué nos
dice el inciso 2 el inciso 2 nos dice
nos dice que el perímetro deje que el
perímetro deje
el perímetro de ge es igual a 10 metros
10.000 metros esto claramente también es
suficiente verdad
si conocemos el perímetro de g conocemos
el perímetro de k con el perímetro de
acá podemos determinar el radio y con el
radio podemos determinar podemos
determinar el área bueno vamos a hacerlo
no tendríamos que hacerlo ahorita la
respuesta ya sería de cada una de ellas
basta pero vamos a ver cuánto nos da
para que veamos cómo le haríamos sale
entonces si sabemos que el área es 25
metros cuadrados entonces tenemos que pi
por radio deje el radio de acá al
cuadrado es igual a 25 por metros
cuadrados y se cancelan con pi entonces
el radio de g es igual a 25 no perdón a
5 tenemos que sacar raíz a 5 metros
de esta forma y podemos encontrar el
perímetro verdad del perímetro de g es
igual a 2 por pipo radio que sería 10
pin 10 metros con eso podemos determinar
el perímetro de acá entonces el
perímetro de acá sería la mitad sería 5
y metros de donde el radio y el radio
pues saber si el rap si el perímetro de
5 metros entonces el radio de acá sería
la mitad del radio de acá sería 2.5
metros que es lo mismo que cinco medios
metros y entonces tenemos que el área
el área de acá sería pi por radio al
cuadrado o sea 25 cuartos 25 cuartos de
metros cuadrados vale y si tenemos la
información del inciso 2 pues ya nos
adelantan un poco tenemos que empezamos
por aquí vale entonces así se haría no
tenemos que hacerlo en el examen de
james pero bueno te estoy enseñando cómo
se hace para que veas que si es posible